Salut ! Aujourd'hui on est mercredi, c'est donc le jour des astuces.
JE VAIS VOUS DONNER UN POUVOIR.
Le pouvoir de résister aux manipulateurs.
Et pour ça, il faut identifier les 7 principales techniques qu'utilisent les manipulateurs.
Il faut quand même admettre une chose, c'est que, on manipule tous à un moment donné.
A partir du moment où on essaie de convaincre quelqu'un,
y a aussi une part de manipulation.
Une manipulation très courante, c'est celle de la précision, celle des chiffres, des statistiques.
Ça crédibilise tout de suite un argumentaire.
"Moi j'pense que 80% des gens qui vont sur You Tube ne regardent pas la télévision."
Le problème c'est qu'ils le pensent, c'est tout.
C'est très fréquent de donner des chiffres qui sortent de nulle part.
La parade pour ce genre de manipulation,
c'est juste de remettre en cause ces chiffres en demandant d'où ils viennent.
Mais pas dans la démarche de le piéger, naaan, juste pour votre information...
En numéro 2, il y a quand même le changement de sujet qui va de paire avec la mauvaise foi
qui est donc de contourner le problème.
Imaginons que je demande à un pote pourquoi il ne m'a toujours pas ramené mon livre
que je lui demande depuis un moment et que là, vraiment, j'en avais besoin.
En bon manipulateur qu'est mon ami,
il devrait me répondre quelque chose du genre
"Je t'ai pas pas ramené ton livre mais tu trouves ça normal, toi, que Julien m'ait pas ramené mes DVD ?"
"Y a un moment donné, ton livre tu me l'as prêté depuis un mois"
"Lui, j'lui ai prêté les DVD depuis 6 mois, t'imagines ... ?"
Attention, manipulation !
Dès qu'on essaie de vous détourner de votre sujet initial, c'est pas bon.
Pour ça, la parade est très simple : c'est la technique du perroquet.
Reformulez, répétez,
mais ne le laissez pas vous emmener dans une autre direction que celle que vous avez choisie au départ.
Ma réponse, ç'aurait été par exemple de dire
"Oui effectivement, c'est très long mais revenons-en à mon livre : pourquoi tu me l'as pas ramené ?
Recentrez le débat !
Technique de manipulation numéro 3 :
le fait de voler la possibilité de quelqu'un.
C'est très utile quand quelqu'un veut vous imposer quelque chose,
de faire semblant qu'il peut vous le prendre.
C'est une technique que connaissent très bien les commerciaux.
Vous voulez acheter un véhicule d'occasion, une voiture, un scooter, peu importe.
Le vendeur vous dit "ah oui mais là, faut venir vite parce que j'ai eu un appel de quelqu'un d'autre qui est sur le coup"
"... et euhhh ....".
"... et ..."
Et est ce qu'il existe vraiment en fait ce mec ?
Ça vous crée un sentiment d'urgence en fait,
comme si on pouvait vous prendre quelque chose
alors que peut-être vous aviez juste appelé pour vous renseigner sur le prix, juste ça.
Et là, d'un coup, ça devient une priorité : l'avoir avant l'autre.
La parade, c'est juste de se contrôler mentalement à ne pas se laisser parasiter par ce genre d'informations.
Et quand elles arrivent, de savoir les détecter, c'est déjà une parade en soi.
Et ça ressemble d'ailleurs à ma 4ème technique de manipulation sur laquelle il faut se méfier,
celle du faux libre arbitre.
Si je vous dis par exemple vous êtes complètement libre de ne pas vous abonner à cette chaîne,
d'ailleurs vous êtes libre de toutes les regarder sans vous abonner, après ça c'est vous que ça regarde.
Il se crée un petit truc bizarre de manipulation
où vous vous dites "ben oui mais eh oh oh, je suis aussi libre de m'abonner si j'ai envie".
Et bam, manipulation !
Soyez très vigilant sur toutes ces phrases qui commencent par
"tu es libre de ...". Là, la parade, c'est la vigilance.
La 5ème technique, elle est très très maligne.
Quand elle est utilisée par quelqu'un, c'est qu'il l'a mûrement réfléchie,
c'est de créer une série de oui pour aboutir à ce qu'on veut.
Imaginez, j'appelle un pote et je lui demande de venir me déménager dans 1 heure, avec sa voiture pour faire tout mon déménagement.
Il y a de fortes chances que lui trouve une excuse pour pas le faire parce qu'il n'a pas envie ce qui serait bien normal d'ailleurs.
On prévient pas les gens 1 heure avant pour un déménagement,
surtout que j'ai besoin de sa voiture et que j'ai besoin qu'il porte des choses lourdes.
Mais je peux l'amener à une série de oui
qui lui fera valider ça au final sans qu'il s'en rende compte.
Puisque quand une personne a commencé à dire oui à des choses simples,
elle a du mal après à dire non, ça devient complètement illogique dans le processus.
Dans mon exemple, je pourrais très bien appeler mon pote pour lui demander de me rendre un tout petit service.
Dans 1 heure, de passer chez moi pour m'aider à descendre la télé.
Je peux pas la descendre tout seul, j'ai peur de l'abimer, donc est ce que tu peux venir ?
Il va dire oui, c'est quasiment sûr.
Et moi je sais déjà qu'il viendra en voiture.
Une fois qu'il va être là et qu'il va commencer à descendre la télé,
je vais lui demander de descendre 2-3 autres objets.
Et puis pour qu'on aille plus vite, peut-être de descendre les cartons,
comme ça on sera 2 à descendre les cartons.
Ça prend quoi ... ? Une petite heure en plus. Rapidement.
Et puis au fur et à mesure de tout ça,
je vais lui demander si on peut pas faire un aller retour avec sa voiture
parce que ça m'aiderait beaucoup en fait, comme j'en ai pas et que tout est en bas ...
Tout le piège se referme, les oui continuent d'affluer, d'avancer
et à un moment donné, il peut pas dire non, parce que c'est plus logique en fait.
Ça de plus ou ça de moins, ça ne pèse plus dans la balance et il en a déjà trop fait.
La parade, c'est de savoir dire non au bon moment.
C'est dès le 2ème oui. Attention, je t'ai dit oui pour ça mais par contre, pas pour ça.
La 6ème technique de manipulation à laquelle on fait le plus souvent face au quotidien,
c'est l'appel à la loyauté ou à la compassion.
Et là, la défense, c'est d'être fort.
Il faut absolument être fort et stopper ça tout de suite, ne pas admettre.
Admettre ça, c'est vous auto manipuler sinon.
Un exemple très concret, un jour, j'ai eu une petite embrouille avec quelqu'un que je connaissais à peine.
Et cette personne là m'a appelé au téléphone pour régler ça, ce qui était très très bien de sa part.
Et dans la conversation, cette personne là me dit
"enfin Fabien, tu me connais, tu sais que je suis honnête, je mens pas"
Dans son argumentaire, je considérais que c'était une technique de manipulation,
donc je l'ai stoppée tout de suite en disant "Non, non, par contre, là je t'arrête"
"je te connais pas, je te connais pas comme tu le dis."
"Je sais pas si t'es honnête et je ne sais pas si tu me mens pas."
"C'est toi qui me dis ça. Je te connais pas assez en tout cas pour dire ça."
Alors évidemment, ça l'a déstabilisée mais au moins on a pu discuter
et je n'ai pas souhaité admettre que je considérais que cette personne là était honnête
puisqu'en fait, je ne la connaissais pas, on c'était croisé qu'une fois.
Et ça m'amène à la dernière technique à laquelle on fait le plus souvent face
qui est la technique de la garantie.
La parade, elle est très facile. Il suffit de remettre en cause cette garantie.
Exemple concret : quelqu'un qui vous dit
"je peux t'assurer que si on fait telle chose, alors on va obtenir tel résultat, c'est sûr."
Au lieu de chercher à savoir si il a raison ou pas,
ou au lieu de lui dire oui directement,
demandez lui pourquoi il est sûr de ça ?  Quel est son argumentaire ?
"Pourquoi t'es sûr qu'on aura ce résultat là ? Je t'écoute."
Des techniques de manipulation comme celles là, j'en ai référencées plus de 150.
Elles ont toutes une parade, il faut les avoir en tête.
On les utilise aussi nous même parfois, sans s'en rendre compte en fait quand on veut convaincre de quelque chose.
C'est bien de pouvoir y faire face,
et c'est bien aussi de pouvoir se contrôler ou du moins savoir ce qu'on fait.
Si vous avez trouvé cette vidéo utile, vous pouvez d'ailleurs mettre un petit pouce en l'air pour le signifier.
Ça c'est pas une manipulation, c'est votre liberté ...
On peut aussi se retrouver dans la télévision directement, à 20h50 sur la chaîne numéro 23.
Y a les dossiers surnaturels qui passent un spécial sur l'hypnose le mentalisme etc... et je suis dedans.
Et si vous le regardez, vous pouvez mettre un petit #TeamMentalo sur twitter.
#TeamMentalo,  c'est le hashtag qu'on a décidé tout ensemble samedi lors du live sur Periscope.
N'hésitez pas à l'utiliser sur les réseaux sociaux qu'on puisse tous retrouver les conversations qu'il y a eu.
C'est donc à 20h50 sur la chaîne numéro 23.
N'oubliez pas de vous abonner. Rendez-vous demain à 17h pour le prochain Mental Vlog. Ciao !